Mr.
Andrew Redleaf: I
think--the, sort of,
first thing that I think most
people think about or the first
question when you're thinking
about financial markets is
whether they're efficient or
not--whether they incorporate
all known information--if it's
possible to do,
sort of, significantly better
than the market as a whole.
I'm not sure--used to be
absolutely received economic
wisdom that financial markets
were efficient.
Now it's--I think it's still
the dominant academic view,
but there's a big debate and
there are partisans on both
sides.
It's actually--to me,
it's actually a fairly simple
question.
The efficient--the notion that
markets are efficient derives
from an a priori theory,
which is the same sort of
theory about all markets.
There are lots of incentives,
people acting in their own
interests--they have to do that.
It's a very appealing kind of
a priori theory,
but the thing about theories is
they're supposed to make
predictions.
If some of the things they
predict don't come true,
the theory has to be
disregarded and there are many,
many, many counter examples to
financial market efficiencies.
On one level,
there are things like companies
that have two different classes
of stock that are economically
identical.
Royal Shell used to have Dutch
shares that traded in Holland
and U.K.
shares traded in London.
Economically identical,
but their prices would
fluctuate and fairly
dramatically.
In '98, I forget which way,
but one of the share classes
was at a 20% discount to the
other and that persisted for
several years,
so you have economically
identical things trading at
different prices.
You have closed end funds,
which are vehicles that own a
set of other securities--trade
as a security listed on the
stock exchange,
but what they do is own other
securities.
And whether they trade to a
discount--whether the security
in the closed end fund trades at
a discount or a premium to the
stuff they own--fluctuates
meaningfully in a way that's
sort of difficult to recognize
with the idea that the
securities should be reflecting
economic value.
You have what are called stubs,
where one public company owns a
significant stake in another
public company.
In instances where the
one--3Com owned Palm,
and the value of its Palm stake
greatly exceeded the total value
of the market capitalization of
3Com;
that persisted for a number of
years.
In general, less volatile
stocks have done better over
time than more volatile stocks,
which is somewhat inconsistent
with the notion of efficient
markets.
Lastly, there is a meaningful
number of individuals and
institutions whose,
sort of,
performance look--whose
performance in portfolios is
really inconsistent with the
markets being efficient.
It can't really be explained
away by--some of them can
but--by luck or by inside
information or by something,
while there's sort of a big
academic debate.
Then lastly,
there are things like the
Internet bubble,
or more recently the housing
bubble,
or--they're not usually called
this, but--the lending bubble
where--or the subprime mess.
Lots and lots of loans,
the securities that people
bought at par that were worth
about somewhere between zero and
$.15 or $.20 and now trade
there.
I don't believe that markets
are efficient and it doesn't
really seem like it should be an
open question.
The people that believe it have
to die and then nobody will
believe it anymore.
Not very many of them change
their mind though they come up
with more convoluted
explanations--clever,
convoluted explanations for the
counter factual--for the things
that happen in reality that the
theory doesn't predict.
So, markets aren't that
efficient.
On the other hand,
sort of doing better than the
markets is a non-trivial
exercise and it's not as easy as
it might appear or as--I mean,
some people think it's
impossible;
other people think it's really
easy.
It's actually not impossible,
but hard, and there are a
number of challenges.
First, for individuals,
I think the primary challenge
is if an individual sticks to,
sort of, areas where they might
have an informational advantage
or at least don't have an
informational disadvantage,
they won't own a diversified
portfolio of securities because
their informational advantage
will be narrow.
They also have sort of limited
access to the gamut of products
and so forth--restricted access
and restricted offerings.
So, that's a challenge for
individuals.
Institutions are sort of
professional investors;
all spend a lot of money on
information, which requires
infrastructure and resources and
so forth.
But the very,
sort of, nature of being an
institution constrains almost
everybody whether it's,
in our case,
all our investors have
thirty-day liquidity.
They can--in mutual funds,
it's daily liquidity,
but their investors tend not to
be as wide-awake.
But that's a constraint on
us--that, except for the
principles, maybe their families
maybe not,
all our money can disappear in
thirty days, so we have to be
cognizant of that.
We have clients that have,
sort of, a set of expectations,
which you also have to,
if not be cognizant about,
sort of deal with.
Then there are,
kind of, universal
psychological challenges--biases
in people's thinking--and a
number of things that are just,
sort of, difficult for human
beings to process and make
intelligent decisions.
I think that's kind of in the
area of mine and one of the
things that drew me to Professor
Shiller and some of his other
colleagues and that's really
universal to not just financial
markets but to all decision
making.
I think, particularly in the
kinds of the things that have a
serious mix of randomness and
skill--that's sort of the
hardest thing for human beings
to process--something that's
kind of an unknown mix of
randomness and skill.
We can understand something
that's fully random and work out
the statistics and be
comfortable with that to some
degree.
Things that are sort of
completely cut and dry,
fully determinative,
we like those too,
but stuff that's mixed is very,
very hard.
I mean, quantum mechanics makes
sense to no human being,
in my view.
In those areas,
people are inclined to do sort
of strange things.
I mean, one thing--I play a
fair amount of--I play a little
bit of poker and I'm very
interested in the game.
It's sort of--it's a little
like the markets and other
things in that there's an
element of randomness and an
element of skill.
One thing that I find
interesting--typically,
if you play poker in a card
room or a casino,
I would say nine times out of
ten somebody sitting at the
table will tell you that they're
not trying;
it almost always happens.
They'll say,
I usually play for more money
and it's hard to concentrate or
I'm just screwing around.
Why do they do that?
What's--why do they not--they
could just be screwing around,
but why do they tell you?
It's kind of my pet theory that
they would rather--they're
setting up in advance to lose.
They would rather lose because
they're sort of screwing around
than--that's easier for them to,
sort of, deal with than
to--they could put out their
best game and they would do
better,
but they might lose anyone
given its, sort of,
randomness.
It is--that's the thing about
really good poker players versus
less good poker players.
Really good poker players play
close to their best all the time
and they're not really bothered
when they lose;
I think that's true in markets
too.
In all sorts of decisions,
what people are inclined to do
or are very interested in doing
is setting up posturing for
credit and blame in advance and
sort of having a pre-made excuse
if things don't go right.
They're more interested,
to some degree at least,
in having an excuse if things
don't go right,
than in sort of maximizing the
chance that things go right
because even maximizing the
chance that things go right,
you can't get it to be 100%;
there's an element of
randomness.
Bad things can happen,
so it's really,
really hard to just focus on
getting things right and not
winning the argument.
Setting yourself up before the
fact so that you can win an
argument after the fact,
so that you didn't--you just
got unlucky.
People are very inclined to see
things as determinative to
attribute--and not just in
markets,
but in the psychology
literature--to believe
if--you're wired to believe if
something--if A happened before
B,
A caused B.
B has to be caused by something
and A happened first,
before it, so that's what--so
they assign causality.
They're also inclined to focus
on sort of recent things--things
they see even if you know
they're irrelevant.
For example,
in the psychology literature,
famous example is--famous kind
of test question is:
a tester will give the person
taking the test the name of two
cities that they've never heard
of and the distance that they're
apart.
So, two random cities,
XYZ and ABC,
are 4,200 miles apart.
Then they'll give them two
other cities that they've never
heard of and ask them how far
apart they think they are.
People anchor to the
information they were given,
even though there's kind of no
causality or no sort of reason
why it should make any
difference.
If the referenced cities,
the first cities,
are 4,200 miles apart,
the answers for the next two
will center around 4,200 miles.
If the referenced cities were
2,500 miles apart,
they'll center about that.
I think it's useful to,
sort of, know all the
hard-wiring biases that people
have to try and de-bias your
thinking,
but it's not easy and in lots
of cases it's not actually
people's objectives.
Any of you watch Mad Money on
CNBC--Jim Cramer?
Any Cramerites?
Nobody?
Well he starts his show,
"Some people want to make
friends;
I just want to make money."
If you watch the show and you
see Cramer, it's pretty
believable.
I think it's true.
Almost everybody in financial
markets is capable of saying
that.
"I don't want to make friends,
I just want to make money."
But for most of them it's not
true.
They have all sorts of things
that they want to do other than
make money.
They have office politics;
they have any number of other
motivations.
That psychology is really hard
and somewhat applicable to not
just markets,
but other things.
Markets aren't efficient,
but it's not that easy to beat
them.
What do we try to do?
I, kind of, would highlight
what I view as three sorts of
principles.
The first, the investment
world, I believe,
divides between coupon
clippers--bonds historically
came with coupons,
actual sort of coupons like the
thing you bring to the grocery
store and get twenty-five cents
off a can of coffee.
So, we have this security and a
ten-year bond would have twenty
coupons attached,
each with a date on them.
When the date came,
you would cut the coupon off
and go to the bank and get your
interest payment.
So, that was called coupon
clipping.
Basically, something that you
would--coupons are things that
you redeem for a stream of money
and,
in my view, the world divides
between coupon clippers--people
that are interested in cash flow
and taking in cash flow--and,
what I would call,
security resellers--people that
own things that they intend to
sell to somebody in the future
at a higher price.
There are successful coupon
clippers and there are
successful securities resellers
and they tend to make their
money off of the unsuccessful
people in the other class.
We try to be--I think investing
is about clipping coupons,
about getting cash flow and
getting and controlling cash
flow,
but there are good resellers.
I think reselling is an element
of things like venture capital.
The best venture capitalists
don't just have great ideas or
whatever, but they take an idea,
they advance it a little bit,
and then they sex it up and
promote it and have a good sense
for what the public will buy and
they get a nice valuation from
the public.
I think that's at least as much
a distinguishing feature between
good venture capitalists among
each other as the quality of
their ideas.
There are sort of–Cramer,
again--Cramer was a good
security reseller--had sort of a
really good--spent a lot of time
and effort kind of figuring out
what is it that people will want
to buy next week.
That's what I'll buy today not
because I'll derive income off
of it, but because it's what
people are going to want next
week and I'll be able to sell it
higher.
That's some art,
some science,
and there are people that are
very, very good at it.
We try to clip coupons.
As to some--that's--it's a
Warren Buffetism--he says,
all investing is about coupon
clipping and the difference
between equities and bonds are
that bonds come with a coupon
that's known and equities have
earnings in the future that you
don't know.
You also don't know that
they'll give them to the equity
owners and to management and not
to--they won't squander in the
future.
But to Buffet it's sort of same
thing--it's clipping coupons and
he describes his job as figuring
out what the coupon is in an
equity and if it's high enough
he likes it.
The first sort of principle to
me is clipping coupons.
The second is that risk is
primarily about what is the
worst thing that can happen.
In a typical security--Wall
Street risk management--a lot of
focus is on what is the range of
moderately probable outcomes.
So, people talk about VAR,
value at risk,
and lots of people try and
build VAR systems.
What they are trying to
determine is how wide is the
band of outcomes.
How wide is the band of stuff
that has a 95% probability or a
98% probability--usually 95% or
98%, but not 99.9%.
If you know I have a 98% chance
of not losing a dollar that
works in the VAR screen and
the--and it won't tell
you--won't distinguish between
whether the 2% chance is of
losing $10 or losing $100.
To me, that's a fundamentally
wrong approach and it's actually
done because it's the sort of
thing that statisticians are
good at.
To some degree,
it's harder to imagine the
worst thing than to
statistically sort of figure out
the middle band.
There's a famous saying,
"If you're good with a hammer,
everything looks like a nail."
That's sort of what that's
like, but the really important
thing is what's the worst thing
that can happen.
The last sort of principle,
which is actually most at odds
with the academic community and
even,
sort of, the general perception
is that you don't get paid for
taking risk,
you get paid for eliminating
risk.
I actually believe in the
history of the planet,
there are very,
very few instances of people
getting paid for taking risk;
they get paid for eliminating
it.
As an example,
if you think about a tightrope
walker in the circus,
there's a conception that he
gets paid because it's a risky
job--he might fall down,
kill himself.
I think that conception is
completely wrong.
The lifetime earnings of a
tightwire walker who falls down
and kills himself aren't very
good.
In fact, what he's getting paid
for is that he practiced a whole
lot when he was a little kid on
a wire that if he fell off of he
wasn't going to get hurt and
that he's really getting paid
for eliminating the risk of
falling off via practice as
opposed to taking it.
You think about drug
development--pharmaceutical
companies and people will say,
well discovering compounds that
are effective drugs is an
uncertain, risky business and so
pharmaceutical companies are
able to get paid for taking that
risk.
I don't think so.
I think they get paid for
applying intelligence and not
testing every--not for the
compounds they test,
but for the ones that they've
eliminated testing for because
they understand the chemistry or
a disease process and have some
idea what sort of compounds are
more likely to work than others.
I don't know if he remembers
this.
When I last explained this to
Professor Shiller,
he said, well what about
insurance companies?
I said, proves my point--the
sort of exact case.
An individual has risk of
certain bad things happening.
If the insurance company has
risk, it's because they've made
a mistake.
If they're sort of doing their
job right, they're actually
diversifying away all the risk
and relying on the law of large
numbers.
A casino does not have a risk
that the law of large numbers
will be repealed and a roulette
table will be a long-term losing
proposition or a craps table
will be a long-term losing
proposition.
They have risks that their
overhead won't cover or that
they won't have--their risk is
that a steady stream of people
won't come and be making a
steady stream of bets at which
each of them has a slightly
negative expectation.
We really want to think,
whenever we look at anything,
what kind of coupons can we
extract?
What's the worst possible thing
that can happen and how can we
eliminate that?
We do that--sometimes it's by
diversification--having a lot at
sort of independent sort of
bets.
More times, it's having an
offsetting kind of position
where we go long one security
that's issued by a company and
short something else that we
think eliminates our risk.
A common kind of position will
be long a high-yielding--a bond
that yields sort of 15% or 16%
and--I mean,
hypothetically a bond trading
at $.60 on the dollar with an 8%
coupon, five-year bond that's
yielding about 18%.
Maybe the company has a $15
equity price and will be short
$.15 of the equity,
which we'll try and keep all
the way down.
If the stock's $20 and we could
stay short $.20 worth of stock
all the way down--if the company
went bankrupt--the company goes
to zero--on our short position,
we'll have taken in about $60,
which is what we owned the
bond--what we paid for the bond.
We have a superior claim in
bankruptcy--we'll recover
something and,
in the meantime,
we get this 8% coupon that we
get to clip.
That's coupon clipping and risk
mitigation.
Now, there's the other side of
the stock going up and we have
to think about how much that can
cost us and whether our coupons
are enough and whether the
difference between the $.60 that
we paid and the $100 that the
bond matures enough--is apt to
cover that.
But that's the sort of the
thing we do and it's coupon
clipping and it's risk
mitigation or risk
elimination--fairly short.
The last thing I thought I'd
talk a little bit about is what
some--what's happening in the
world today and the financial
system today,
which to us it's--if you're in
trading and investing,
things happen in your world and
they're just unbelievable.
You go outside and you talk to
people that have jobs and lives
or go to school and they're
completely unaware that--they
have absolutely no idea that
this really amazing,
unbelievable thing just
happened.
There's a shortage in hard,
red, winter wheat,
so Minneapolis Wheat has gone
from kind of $10 to $24,
now to about $18 or $20,
but in one day it went from $20
to $24.5--a 22% move in
Minneapolis Wheat.
Most of the people in the world
had no idea that that had
occurred and it makes absolutely
no difference to them.
One of the things that's sort
of happening in the world that's
sort of central to the people
that look at this all the time,
but of maybe less direct
relevance to people that have
everyday jobs,
is that the banking-–more
so than--I mean,
I've been at this for thirty
years.
In those thirty years,
there have been lots of mini
crises and violent moves up or
down--dramatic squeezes or
liquidations--but more so than
any time in the past thirty
years,
the banking system is really
closed.
The big American banks are not
functioning.
Their doors are open and people
come and go everyday,
but they're not really open for
business.
They're neither making loans
nor selling the loans they have
and it's starting--it's
affecting the fringes of
Corporate America now--not yet
all of it.
And it's what happened in Japan
from '90 to--is it over in
Japan?
Maybe or maybe not.
They usually talk about it as
the "lost decade," where
Japanese banks were not
liquidated but they were not
really in business.
That's happened now primarily
as the result of losses in,
now all mortgages,
but mortgages and levered
loans.
In my view--the Fed has
dramatically cut interest rates.
We started from 5% to 3%,
but three-quarters of it--a
quarter at a time every Fed
meeting,
which are--Fed meetings are
generally about six weeks apart.
But then, 1 ¼
of it within a two-week
period--from 4 ¼
to 3--and they're talking
about--looks like they'll go
from 3 to 2 ½
whenever the next--when's the
next Fed meeting?
Within a couple of weeks.
The markets are saying they're
going to go all the way back to
one, which was the low for
short-term rates.
To some degree they say their
objective is two-fold:
to spur economic growth as the
credit crunch slows economic
activity.
Also, I mean,
kind of independently or
complimentarily as a corollary
to that--to free up the
financial system and to help
financial institutions.
It's kind of my contention that
it's actually hurting financial
institutions.
It's actually having the effect
of not letting the markets
clear.
It's nature--financial--I mean
that--when I was explaining it
to Professor Shiller,
he said he didn't quite follow
it, so I probably shouldn't try
it, and he knows more than I do.
It's a very interesting time in
that we're having a--we have
consumers under pressure because
of their overextension of credit
and they're having overpaid for
houses over the last handful of
years.
We have kind of a slowing
economy either because of that
or because the economy kind of
slows every once in a while.
We have financial institutions
under stress or duress and,
unlike the previous time,
we have headline inflation of
4.3%.
I think it's higher--I think
lots of economists think it's
lower, but it's--headline
inflation is higher than nominal
interest rates.
We have a very weak currency.
The dollar has gone from buying
a little over 1 Euro to buying
2/3 of a Euro in a couple of
years and 130 Yen to 100 Yen,
1.5 Australian Dollars to a
little over 1 and the--and in
that scenario,
there are more problems than
policy tools,
so any policy action has a
downside, which makes it an
interesting time.
About half the time.
Questions?
Student: You mentioned
that things are [inaudible],
do you think that [inaudible]?
For example,
do you think that mortgage
[inaudible]
will have a negative
impression?
Mr.
Andrew Redleaf: I think
that the question is whether
markets are more apt to
overprice versus underprice.
Whether they're more
inefficient when things are
going up or when things are
going down.
I don't think I have a systemic
sort of view.
I mean, lately they've been
more inefficient,
in my view, because the Fed's
creating too much money.
In recent years,
there have been more examples
of things that are priced too
high than things that are priced
too low,
but there are both and the
market makes mistakes in both
directions.
Student: I actually have
two questions.
One, do you think an individual
investor should listen to
Cramer?
Two, what do you think are the
best ways an individual investor
can make the best return in the
market these days?
Mr.
Andrew Redleaf: Again,
this is something that I think
Ben Stein agrees with,
but just about nobody else.
I think for individuals,
instead of thinking of,
I want to have a portfolio--I
used to have a portfolio and I
should be invested all the time
and I should divide it up--cash,
stocks, and bonds--depending
upon how old I am.
I think people's default
position should be
cash--individual's default
position should be cash--and
they should only make
investments if there's really
a--if they can see a really
compelling case.
Over the course of time,
fairly compelling cases do come
up and they're not--and
individuals are in as good a
position as professionals to see
that.
So sometime in your lifetime,
stocks, equities as a group,
will be cheap by most of the
standards that have worked in
the past.
Professor Shiller,
in his books,
he's got current multiple of
trailing ten-year earnings.
Good measure--sort of takes the
cyclicality out of earnings and
you can see over history how
that multiple has varied.
You've done very well--you've
done poorly if--for the most
part, if stocks have done much
better if you've bought them at
a point that looks cheap on that
graph than one that looks
expensive.
Sometime in your lifetime,
you'll get an opportunity for
stocks to look cheap on that
measure.
They'll probably,
at the same time,
look cheap on a price-to-book
basis, on a dividend yield
basis--they tend to move
together--and you can sort of
look at them and say,
equities as a class are cheap,
I have a compelling reason to
take money out of cash and put
it into equities now.
I mean, I think a few years
ago, as the housing bubble was
taking off and going full board,
as it was easier and easier for
more and more people who
normally couldn't have bought
houses to go from renting to
owning homes,
residential REITs,
apartment house REITs were
again, on obvious historical
measures,
interesting,
maybe even compelling.
So, you could buy apartment
buildings for way less than it
would cost to replace them.
You could, with public
apartment REITs,
you could get between a 5% and
9% current income--compound
interest rates were down at 2%
or 3%.
That was pretty compelling as
an asset class and worked really
well.
Municipal bonds right
now--municipal bonds yield more
than the equivalent
Treasuries--approximately
1.1,1.2 times--that's pretty
compelling.
The only other time that
happened was when there was sort
of talk of their losing their
tax exemptions and tax rates
were going down.
Tax rates are going up--there's
no talk about losing their
exemption--that's pretty
compelling.
Professor Robert
Shiller: You said that
individuals' default investment
should be cash.
I just want to point out that
contradicts one of our readings.
Jeremy Siegel,
Stocks for the Long Run,
says the default should be
equities.
Am I misunderstanding you or
are you-- Mr.
Andrew Redleaf: I disagree
with him.
Ben Stein, I think,
is the only person who sort of
agrees with me.
He wrote a book,
Yes You Can Time the
Market, and he sort of
basically says,
only buy things when you have a
good reason--a really compelling
reason to own them.
I think--I don't know what he
says about this,
but I think most of the
equity--to me,
the historic kind of case for
equities is survivor--is
U.S.-centric and it's survivor
bias.
Obviously, the U.S.
went from a kind of average
agrarian country to the
industrial colossus of the
world,
so obviously--or as a corollary
to that--equities did really,
really well.
It's not 100% clear that over
the next hundred years that Asia
might not--China,
India, the tigers,
collectively--might not surpass
us or the world might not do
that well for the next hundred
years.
The last hundred years,
in the U.S.,
don't really have that much
predictive power.
Student: We talk a lot
in this class about trying to
correlate to the equity premium.
Can you talk a little bit about
what you see the advantages of
bonds, why you focus so much on
bonds--getting a little bit away
from the securities--and what
advantages do you think would
make good investments?
Mr.
Andrew Redleaf: Here,
I've convinced some people,
though David Swensen really
disagrees with me.
If you read his Pioneering
Portfolio Management on the
syllabus, he really has a
preference for equities.
What I liked about fixed
income, I think fixed income is
inherently more analyzable
because you have,
sort of, specified coupons and
matured--a specified coupon and
a specified maturity and you
have a fixed income.
Either they pay you or they
have to reorganize and--they
either pay you interest or they
have to reorganize and they pay
you principle or they have to
reorganize.
It's inherently more analyzable.
Stocks really have to be cheap
because, in general,
they don't pay out their
earnings and sometime in the
future they're pretty apt to do
something stupid and you can't
tell.
On the one hand,
I do think if there's a stock
that is selling for four,
five,
or six times the earnings and
you have good reason to believe
that the earnings are going up,
something's--when a stock sells
for a mid-single digit earnings
multiple, the market is telling
you that--the market is saying
that earnings are coming down.
If you have good reason to
believe that earnings are going
up, if in fact you're right--in
that case,
when you buy the stock you are
making a bet on the earnings
going up.
If the earnings go up,
you'll get paid twice because
the multiple will go up too;
that's sort of the way things
trade.
When you just--you buy
something at a--RIM,
the maker of Blackberry,
sells for fifty,
sixty, seventy times earnings;
when you buy that stock,
earnings can go up.
You could think,
I'm buying the stock because I
think earnings--you have to
think earnings are going to go
up twelve-fold to get it down to
four times earnings,
which will take a long,
long time.
They are--if you know earnings
are going to double,
you really don't know very much
about what will happen to the
stock price because if they're
going to double over the next
two years,
hypothetically--if you're right
on that, it doesn't matter
because the multiple could very,
very easily go from fifty to
twenty-five.
So, it's--and in the end,
they'll never pay you any
dividends.
How do you collect--How do you
ever collect a coupon?
How do you ever get a hold of
cash flow?
I just hate owning stocks and I
love people sending me checks,
which is what a bond--
Student: Tell us--the
criticisms that I often read
about in the news media
[inaudible]
is that in an industry that
a service that benefits
society,
in a sense, hedge fund managers
they [inaudible]
the markets because they have a
better understanding of how the
world works a lot better than
[inaudible].
I was wondering how you feel
about that?
Mr.
Andrew Redleaf: Well,
I think I--a couple of points.
First, I do think it helps the
world to have security prices
that are closer to their
accurate value than further away
and more tending towards their
fair value over time than
gyrating completely randomly.
If hedge funds could obsolete
themselves--if hedge funds could
make markets completely
efficient, it would benefit the
world a lot--is one.
And to the extent that they
help make markets efficient,
I do think they help the world.
I do sort of agree.
I think involved investors also
improve the performance of the
country's fixed assets and that
helps the world too.
Hedge fund people aren't--I
think more and more that'll be a
part of what hedge funds do.
I mean for--we gave it up,
but we owned Sun Country along
with the Petters Group,
which is a Minneapolis based
point-to-point airline--competes
with Northwest.
It was kind of an experiment,
somewhat in behavioral
economics.
We had distinct ideas about
what their business strategy
should be.
We couldn't--Petters and
Whitebox actually did not
disagree, but the--Whitebox got
completely disillusioned with
management and wasn't--so we
sold our stake to Petters.
If our ideas were good,
it really would have benefited
consumers in the Twin Cities and
I do think that people who have
real money at stake are apt
to--over time and on average,
their ideas will be better than
people who don't have anything
at stake.
I mean, activist investors,
which are mostly hedge funds,
I think often either make
management better via
competition or on balance their
ideas are right and they
certainly challenge–
force--management to at least
consider alternatives.
I think if--I wrote in my last
letter--I just read Paul
Krugman's book--The New York
Times editorialist--The
Conscience of a Liberal.
Like a lot of hedge fund
people, I'm pretty free market,
right-wing conservative,
but I think unlike--hedge fund
compensation is really a market
result.
It's the result of negotiations
between informed parties of
roughly equal economic clout and
sophistication.
Executive compensation is not
the result of arm's length
negotiations.
There's a new,
I think a Yale study on
executive compensation.
Something like 96% of Fortune
500 CEOs get their full
severance package,
even if they're dismissed for
anything other than a major
felony.
That they can perform
badly--they can be found to have
breached their fiduciary duty,
but they still get a lot,
so I wouldn't--I'm on the hedge
fund side and against the sort
of company management side.
Professor Robert
Shiller: Can you tell the
story of backdating of options?
I started to tell it in class.
Mr. Andrew Redleaf: Sure.
Sort of--the history--when
bonds are governed by what's
called "an indenture,"
which is the sort of legal
agreement between the company
and bond holders.
In a typical bond indenture,
if a company fails to file
financial statements on time
that's an event of default under
their bond agreement and usually
the remedy for an event of
default is you can demand
immediate payment--acceleration
and immediate payment.
We--in general,
people don't read every--people
own bonds without reading the
indenture.
They're long,
they're not written in English;
in most set of circumstances
they are irrelevant.
So, we actually didn't really
know this until we owned a bond
in the company that didn't--that
couldn't file their financial
statements on time.
Somebody else owned them,
and discovered them,
and demanded that they get
paid, and ended up negotiating
with the company,
and we got a kicker.
So, that was kind of our first
experience--the thing that made
us aware that not filing
financial statements was an
event of default and,
therefore, something that would
entitle you to the payment
immediately.
So, for companies that could
pay you back,
but their bonds are trading
below par, probably because they
have a low coupon.
So, if a bond was issued when
interest rates were lower,
they might have a 4% coupon
when the prevailing rate is 6%.
So, if it's a four-year bond,
it would trade at about $90,
so it would be yielding 6%.
But if they default,
you can buy them at $90 and if
they can't file their financial
statements, you're entitled to
par.
We were interested in finding
bonds trading below par where we
thought there was a chance that
companies would not file their
financial statements on time.
It turned out at the time,
one of the big causes of
companies not filing financial
statements on time was if they
had backdated the stock options.
They know what back dating is?
Professor Robert
Shiller: We discussed that.
Mr.
Andrew Redleaf: If they had
backdated their stock options,
they'd have to restate their
financials;
they'd have to
investigate--takes time and so
forth--and they would delay
filing their financial
statements.
We tried to identify companies
that we thought had backdated
their stock options.
We bought a database,
we cleaned it up,
and we basically looked at
their pattern of stock option
issuance and tried to figure out
the probability of it having
been caused by chance.
For companies that we thought
had backdated stock options,
that we could buy their bonds
at what they would trade for
without this potential event of
default.
That was kind of a riskless
trade because if they filed on
time, we hadn't paid anything.
If they were late,
we had the prospect of getting
par quickly.
In the very beginning,
the kind of history--there was
the first trade,
where somebody else discovered
that a company couldn't file
their financial statements
because they had bad
recordkeeping or whatever;
that one was not option-related.
That first one was kind of
happenstance.
The next couple of times,
companies announced that they
were apt to delay their
financial statements.
The first few times,
you could buy their bonds at
the same price as before they
had announced that and
potentially owed you par.
But that did not–here,
in terms of market efficiency,
it didn't last forever and
after three or four times,
companies would announce that
they were going to delay their
filings.
Lo and behold,
their bonds would go up because
people had discovered that you
might be entitled to par.
When it stopped working--like
waiting--we tried to anticipate
what companies might not be able
to file and buy their bonds in
advance.
We gave the SEC our study and
algorithm--they wouldn't tell us
what they're out--exactly who
they were targeting and how,
though I got the sense that
their approach was similar to
ours.
They sort of seemed--even
though they didn't say anything,
when we were talking to them,
they seemed sort of pleased
that--when we did something,
you could see they--when they
were sort of pleased,
we took that to mean that that
was what they were doing.
They were sort of happy or
thinking that that got it right.
As it happens,
so far that we've been
involved, four companies have
argued in court that failure to
file financial statements is not
an event of default.
We won the first case,
which we really thought settled
it.
We've subsequently lost two and
one is pending.
The wording is slightly
different in all the indentures,
but in general,
we've settled eight or nine
cases;
companies sort of agreed and we
negotiated a settlement.
In terms of whether hedge funds
are an instrument of social good
or not, the litigation companies
argue that we're opportunists,
and we went in and bought more
bonds after they filed late,
and we haven't been injured,
and it's basically unfair that
they should have to pay us par.
I did consider this sort of
noble work because I think
companies should honor their
agreements.
It's also the case that if a
company paid off their bonds or
settled them,
they settled it for all
bondholders and not just us.
If anything,
other bondholders get to free
ride on us but I think hedge
funds–again,
it's sort of a good thing if
documents and agreement have
meaning and that requires active
engaged parties;
otherwise, the party that's
active and engaged will take
advantage of the other.